the benefit and actually the beauty
of having a public failure at least for
me
it took away any fear of failure because
you fast forward 10 years later and i'm
stronger as a person
i've already failed publicly i lived
through it it was horrible at the time
and all that did was just allowed me to
move forward at a very fast pace and
create an amazing company
[Music]
the real rail is the world's largest
marketplace for authenticated luxury
resale
when i was growing up both of my parents
mostly because they're artists really
loved beautiful things
and that didn't necessarily mean
beautiful new things so
my mother would go to people's homes if
they had a nice rug she'd say when
you're ready to sell it i'll buy it from
you
and my father and i would go to the
junkyard to scavenger for beautiful
pieces which he would then refurbish
and turn into something else
at the moment in time when i shut the
company down to return money to
shareholders i was thinking about my
employees
and making sure they had a pay package
and future jobs
and also my husband had asked me for a
divorce that day
so there was a lot going on and i would
say six months later
it really hit me that this was really
bad for my career
it didn't help that every major
newspaper and every tech article was
written not about the company and not
about the times
but also about me personally and
pretty pretty horrible things i was
called the dumbest person in silicon
valley
and so it was it was a hard time
after pets even though it had a lot of
negative press i didn't really
realize how much of it would sort of
stick to me
um and how my options may be limited
after that until i met with a recruiter
and he said basically after he said well
pets.com
it's such a blow up your career is over
and you know i wouldn't show you to any
comp i wouldn't introduce you to any
companies
but hearing that made me go okay well
what am i going to do about it
you know and uh clearly i'm not gonna be
able to get my dream job from someone
else and i'm gonna have to create my own
that's exactly how it that
hit me not like always wrong or he's a
jerk
it was like okay i'm taking this as
valid
how what does that mean for me it means
that i should start my own company
because
i'm other people don't believe in me
right now
in the valley it's small world but i
believe in myself
so that's my best option
with the real rail our biggest
accomplishment is bringing awareness
to the amount of fashion in landfill and
the
incredible benefits of buying and
consigning previously owned goods we're
doing it on
everything we do on our website we're
doing it on our own company we're now
carbon neutral and even more importantly
we're working with our congressmen
and multiple people in the government to
help change
laws to actually increase the awareness
of the importance of recirculating used
goods
and conscious consumption and if we make
any dent on that given the environmental
situation the world's in i'm going to
feel like
i'm going to feel pretty good about what
i've done and what the company's done
i would say that you need to think of
your career as a long-term
investment i would encourage you to take
risks
never stop taking risks and even when
you think you're there you're not there
yet
that learning happens at every age and
you're going to have
you will have setbacks you know figure
it out don't give up
this is the long game don't play the
short game and
more importantly you have to love what
you do
and you also have to be conscious of the
choices you're making
so if you become an entrepreneur and i'd
love to see more female entrepreneurs
recognize that that will consume your
life
so be conscious about it is that really
the track i want to go
or do i want to balance my home life
with
job for a while and then i can do it
later the other thing is you know
really the real reality started at 53 so
clearly it's never too late
but i had a lot of great experience to
build on
so you know life life can be long
and also take care of your body and your
mind and you know you have to eat right
you have to exercise
you have to give yourself a spiritual
spiritual nourishment
so take care of yourself along the way